[Música]
es un gran placer estar con ustedes aquí
en el estudio 26 de radio canadá para
presentarles esta edición de canadá en
las américas café de este viernes 3 de
mayo en vivo y en directo por youtube
facebook live nuestro sitio internet
rcn punto ósea y nuestra aplicación
claro está hoy bueno un caluroso saludo
a todas y todos los que nos están
escuchando en este momento oyendo
también y gracias por su agradable
compañía hoy en estudio con leonora
chapman paloma martínez y leonardo kees
- bienvenidas y bienvenidos igualmente
pablos
753 2006 y quiere confundir a la gente
yo les dije el 26
estamos sobrados
tenemos dos invitados como se habrán
podido dar cuenta tenemos a dos
escritores hispano canadienses
jose antonio villalobos de perú y germán
rodríguez de el salvador así que
bienvenidos gracias gracias por la
invitación si ellos jose antonio y
germán participan en el festival
metrópolis un festival literario que se
lleva anualmente aquí en la ciudad de
montreal y bien allí aprovechó ya que
estamos entonces para decirle estamos
innovando hoy aquí en este programa a
decirlo porque estamos vamos a realizar
el 1er
sorteo de canadá en las américas café
que hacemos en la web y leonora mira
para que la gente para que se se pueda
haber un ap tyson a que la gente pueda
[Música]
historias de montreal de las historias
de montreal entonces este libro que
acaba en ver la carátula y lo vamos a
sortear en el programa de hoy y en
vamos a hacer una pregunta facilísima o
una pregunta
digo que sí que son 20 y que es una
pregunta que necesitamos respuestas y
bueno como les decía es algo inédito acá
en nuestro programa solíamos hacerlos en
tiempos del castor mensajero ustedes
recordarán el castor en tiempos de
bonanza exacto en otros tiempos mejores
donde había efectivamente un poco más de
abundancia pero bueno qué le vamos a
hacer así son las cosas cuando son del
alma
bueno en vamos a comenzar con las cosas
inéditas muy rápidamente que les haya
llamado la atención
leonora german tú nos va a hablar del
mes del patrimonio de llamas ya me llama
siempre la atención este tipo de
festivales que hay en canadá y este es
el
el festival access and see que se lleva
a cabo todo el mes de mayo en montreal
es el festival más antiguo de canadá que
involucra a los canadienses de origen
asiático en este festival no sé si se
pueden ver las fotografías que tenemos
es un festival donde hay una mezcla se
presentan artes visuales con danza
teatro vídeos música poesía y participan
unos una veintena de países en este
festival con sus presentaciones y que
vienen de japón y korea también vienen
de india bangladesh nepal sidi lanka en
fin la la es
es increíble la elección que uno puede
ver de arte en este tipo de festival
hablamos con el secretario de este
festival que es milton tanaka pues sí ya
le hace un recuento un poco de las cosas
más importantes que vamos a encontrar en
este festival que empezó hace 23
este por ejemplo es el título esté
escrito en farsi y es un conjunto
musical que viene a menudo a montreal
son muy buenos
bueno en fin entonces eso es lo que yo
destaco porque además hay obras de arte
de pinturas que es muy muy interesante y
son cosas que en general nosotros no
tenemos acceso cotidianamente también
hay un homenaje especial a las primeras
naciones de canadá que vemos ahí que hay
es un profesor antropólogo creo también
de una universidad aquí en quebec donde
va a presentar una charla también
informativa sobre la cultura de las
primeras naciones en fin eso es un poco
lo que yo destacó que me llama la
atención este esta semana y que marca de
alguna forma con metrópolis blue que
este año comenzó un poco más tarde
porque en general es en el mes de
febrero más o menos que se hace
yo creo que lo abrazaron por
la razón la cual se me escapa en el
momento pero que da inicio de alguna
forma al festival de festivales aquí en
montreal que hay de todos los tipos y de
todo lo que quieras no entonces seguimos
con los temas inéditos paloma tú te
interesaste al regreso de las orcas en
vancouver exactamente pablo es una muy
buena noticia según los científicos
porque resulta que el regreso de las
orcas significa también que el medio
ambiente está mejorando o sea y que por
eso quieren volver a ese puerto de
vancouver de hecho hay unas imágenes que
probablemente estamos buscando en este
momento que son esas orcas que se están
paseando justamente cerquita de la
ciudad y entonces son peligrosas son
peligrosísimas pero no hay que ir hace
mucho tiempo que no se acercaban a la a
esa zona del puerto porque estaba muy
contaminado entonces ahora han hecho el
gobierno de la provincia de columbia
británica ha hecho varias cosas para que
el medio ambiente de las orcas de medio
ambiente
el puerto se mejore entre otras cosas
puedes limpiar el agua limpiar las zonas
industriales que estará al lado del
puerto y resulta que ahora las orcas han
vuelto entonces es una muy buena noticia
me parece a mí este tipo de orcas en
particular si no se cae uno al agua
mientras que yo estando todo está bien
pero bueno en el mismo carácter que
willy no pasa nada
diferente
otra cosa interesante de esto es que no
solamente el agua y el medio ambiente
está limpio sino también las poblaciones
de los animales de los que las orcas se
alimentan que son ya sabemos los lobos
marinos y las focas eso es los animales
de los que se alimentan están las
poblaciones son muy grandes ahora
entonces justamente por la misma razón
es el mediante bueno a mí me parece
simpático que la gente se ponga tan
feliz del regreso de estos animalitos
porque el nombre en inglés justamente es
ya
la ballena asesina entonces pues cuando
uno las ve paseándose por ahí en el
cuerpo pues bueno yo hice un reportaje y
justamente lo que es interesante es que
también hay nueva legislación en canadá
con respecto a las orcas y al cautiverio
de orcas y otros animales marinos
entonces bueno bueno también
una verruga en las costas de eeuu y con
un arnés carmesí la necesidad de algunos
entre a rusia por enviar
[Risas]
nosotros tiene que confesar que están
viendo los toros desde la barrera
somos muy creativos leonardo gimeno tú
no vas a hablar de efemérides pero
también de star wars del 5 de mayo se
tiene que vivir el cambio de ipad es el
primer día de trabajo
memoró y también se conmemora un año más
del fallecimiento de alfonsín se
acuerdan
gran gran gran milos lo veo brasilera
silencio en imola
no se inmoló porque fue el laborista no
lo hizo hasta ahora nadie o sea es
realmente un hito en cuestión piloto en
el documental es muy bueno del caja3 y
donde cuenta la historia de historia
gusta y justamente está hasta hasta el
accidente en imola bueno el más famoso
que es su imagen
no lo pasa es que su imagen es como es
como comparar messi con maradona
son dos cosas distintas dos épocas
distintas
dos formas de conducir distintos dos
tecnologías de auto no a fangio era otra
cosa aparte justamente por eso porque
antes se corría el amaneramiento
que sobrepasó en campeonatos
quiero recordar que el tiempo de 2.519
se moría leonardo da vinci dos años 500
años de lavado vinci el 3 de mayo
es el día d watmore y shakespeare hoy
exactamente hoy hace un montón de años
el 4 de mayo es mañana y festejamos el
día de star wars fonética
es porque mañana es el
4 de mayo wolford y el lema de force de
entonces
después y el 5 de mayo es una cosa que
me ha volado la casa realmente porque
uno asocia cinco amados desde que vivo
en este país a méxico
y le pregunté a mi amiga mexicana y el
síntoma la batalla de puebla en la que
el ejército mexicano legal o el ejército
francés pero no hay fiesta es una
conmemoración como histórica y como la
escuela como que la gente nacional de
méxico exacto como promueven las
películas marinas la fiesta nacional no
para reivindicarla hermano luna pero ahí
está siempre se conmemora el día de la
invasión
abrir abrir y el 5 de mano también nacía
hace muchísimos años atrás
carlitos marx así que esa salita vital
pues el capitalismo señor bueno muy bien
fantástico a mí lo que me llamó la
atención esta semana es esta joven
originaria de toronto que se ganó un
concurso que fue lanzado por el museo de
louvre de parís en francia y había un
concurso no participaron 180 mil
personas y la pregunta era por qué sería
usted el huésped ideal de la mona lisa
entonces ella agarró esa pregunta y al
poco le dio en medio medio en serio me
dio a la risa y propuso su respuesta y
finalmente fue ella la que ganó y entre
las cosas que ganó fue una en una copa
bueno una noche en el libro hay en el
louvre hay la vemos
tomándose una copa de champán frente a
la mona lisa
eso sí sola no nos dice la historia por
lo que no nos dice qué fue lo que
contestó vall no sabemos si es la mona
lisa una de las ocho copias canadá no
vuelto por él
[Risas]
cerca ya te voy a hacer yo encuentro
bueno entonces el premio era una copa de
champaña que vimos ahí es una escena
gastronómica delante de la venus de milo
y una visita guiada en el museo de
cierto porque no había nadie entonces se
han ido ya
si aún no está y nunca buenos peces
bailo aprietan lo empujan para ver a la
monalisa justamente hay como que es
imposible porque el cuadrito imaginar
amores
finalmente un cuadrito y es una de las
ocho copias
[Risas]
a mí lo que me pegó al revés fue el
garnica de picasso es fuera del texto
[Risas]
en todo caso la cereza sobre él son de
era la al pasar la noche en la pirámide
lo interesante de esta semana un premio
así y bueno ya sin más rodeos vamos a
pasar a nuestros invitados porque además
tenemos un sorteo que hacer
jose antonio vive ahora en los ángeles
yo estaba convencido de que vivía en
toronto también pues hace mucho desde
este año
pero tú hair más si vives en calgary yo
estoy en calgary sí
pero ya han estado ustedes de paso en
montreal industrial hemos venido muchas
veces llegaron directamente de allá de
perú y del salvador directamente el
salvador a toronto 25 años en toronto
vivió un año y algo en vancouver y ya
terminen en cargar y hace falta montreal
visitado mucho
y yo de perú a toronto no de lima
toronto y ahora de toronto los años 15
claro 15 años entonces vas y vuelves por
enero es la razón de el hogar y la razón
por la cual germán y josé antonio
eleonora es simple y tiene que ver con
un festival lo dijiste el festival
[Música]
azul metrópolis en castellano he visto
casi lo pones s
ustedes vienen a presentar un libro un
libro que es lo presentes son historias
de montreal en la cual pues participan
25 escritores de hispano canadienses
muchos están instalados aquí en montreal
otros como ustedes que andan dando
vueltas por ahí hay que decir josé
antonio que este no es el primer libro
que publican ustedes ya hubo unas
historias de toronto hace dos años
exactamente diez años
con la misma intención es decir traer a
escritores bueno dime porque lo que
sucede es que
se forma la comunidad de autores se
imagina en el 2014 y es uno de los que
fundamos está donde la comunidad de
autores en toronto y fue un evento muy
simpático porque la idea era reunir a un
grupo de autores hispanos yo me puse en
contacto con muchos autores algunos
respondieron otros no y bueno la idea
era reunirnos tomarnos un café
conocernos presentar nuestro trabajo
literario
y aprender no de nosotros mismos y el
evento resultó muy simpático muy
singular entonces a raíz de eso nos
hicimos muy amigos con primero con marta
bat y es una gran escritora que está en
toronto que está ahora acaba de llegar
ella es reciente de toronto sí claro
marta batis viene de la feria
internacional del libro de bogotá ha
viajado montreal para el blue metrópoli
y estará presentando también el libro
mañana con nosotros entonces con marta
gratis y con juan gavasa que es un
periodista español gran editor que
también estaría alto también está en
toronto blogs
formamos el equipo editorial de
historias de nuestra primera obra fue
historia de toronto en la que reunimos a
12 autores hispanos canadienses y fue un
trabajo muy bonito nos gustó mucho
trabajar con las historias no era
simplemente recopilar un grupo de
cuentos sino dedicarle el protagonismo
total a toronto como personaje no
entonces eso fue muy particular los
autores escribieron historias muy
simpáticas y bueno el libro fue así ahí
hay una relación jose antonio entre el
hecho de que sean 25 escritores de
origen latinoamericano o hispano español
y el hecho de que sean inmigrantes en
las historias que ellos cuentan bueno
hay definitivamente hay una relación
pero yo creo que lo más importante es
resaltar que en canadá también se
escribe en español
no somos escritores de origen hispano es
verdad este escritor es canal y ahora
también son los escritores canadienses y
yo creo que eso es lo importante
incorporarnos dentro del contexto como
ciudadanos canadienses y demostrar que
también nosotros escribimos nuestra
historia en español porque no
justamente será una de mis preguntas y
tláhuac y germán
el escritor hispano canadiense escribe
por excelencia en español se entiendo
bien o también escribe en inglés o en
francés yo creo que depende del escritor
y como se sienta el de cómodo con los
diferentes del lenguaje yo escribo en
inglés pero también pero la mayoría de
mi trabajos en español lengua mi lengua
materna y si yo creo que depende de la
comodidad de cada de cada escritor como
es posible escribir en español en lengua
castellana en canadá y vivir de esa ese
arte bueno yo quiero que también todo
depende la verdad cómo se manejan las
cosas yo creo que si se sigue un camino
y se es estratégico podría decir que sí
pero es un camino muy largo muy largo y
también depende de cómo se viva en qué
parte de casa donde es un poco más como
vivir yo creo que se podría es no es
fácil y no solamente dedicándose a
escribir a la ficción sino haciendo
varias cosas como periodismo
medios sociales yo creo que si se se
combinan distintas actividades se puede
no solamente una pausa tenemos por ahí
ya mensajes de nuestros hoy vamos a ver
lo vamos a ver en el si realidad dice
abrazos live altera saludos amigos del
pse y nelson contracción con saludos de
barranquilla colombia caqui guerrero y
se saludos desde bogotá después manfred
echeverría saludos amigos
gilbert no han jugado algo de de managua
nicaragua se desarrolla charla y saludo
de bogotá colombia a toda la mesa de
trabajo invitados carlos severino dice
desde graba está pernambuco brasil
buenas tardes misma esa mora de saludos
desde salvatierra setting solimán de
burla saludos a todos ustedes desde el
pp y la espera de escucharlos cada
viernes dice
tsering nelson con tres rincón ya te voy
a echar un cuento perfecta colombiana
dicho por pablo
elisabeth elizabeth díaz león dice
saludos yo soy de pero bueno y listo
tener que quedarse firmeza ya tiene el
cañón porque vamos a hacer
el concurso bien y le vamos a hacer la
pregunta así que es tiempo también para
que para qué
tú tenías una pregunta para germán
porque germán habla de vivir el título
de su libro es de su libro no de su de
su cuento es viviendo y la copa de vino
y como decíamos usted no vive aquí en
montreal pero conoce montreal a través
de vivienne por lo que posible
[Risas]
el número de la página y me fui al final
del final
como como aprecia como es decir como se
ve a montreal reflejada en esta historia
como no podemos cuenta la historia como
tal porque la gente que puede leerla
pero de qué manera montreal cbs se ve y
se ve ahí como una de las cosas que me
gustan más de montreal es es la forma
urbana de montreal donde está la belleza
del arte pero también está la parte la
parte oscura de los callejones de las de
las de las escaleras en espiral es
entonces ese es en tanto entre entre la
belleza de una ciudad
antigua con una arquitectura antigua
pero también todo lo que puede traer la
oscuridad a la noche y lo que pueda
pasar eso es lo que refleja el cuento
que viviste 16 años en toronto ya
escribiste también para el libro
historias de toronto ahora es montreal
cuál es en el cuento que vos plasmas te
aquí en este libro cuál sería la
diferencia en la diferencia entre una
ciudad y otra según tu visión porque
viste tantos años en toronto cuál es la
diferencia con montreal que te llama la
atención
montreal mí siempre me llamó muchísimo
la atención y siempre ha sido una ciudad
muy frecuente en la proximidad entre
toronto y montreal a pesar de que
conduciendo son solamente 6 horas tal
vez que para mí eran insignificantes y
siempre era un volvía no siempre venía a
visitar a visitar amigos a conocer más
de montreal a descubrir la ciudad y
enamorarme de ella porque es una ciudad
que se presta mucho a eso no tiene un
romanticismo muy especial y yo creo que
esa es una de las características
qué principales qué diferencia en
montreal de toronto no la historia es
como una es como casi como una señora
que tiene ese don de seducir muy mucha
clase mucho estilo no muchas oficinas
soy el yo y el hecho de que sea una
ciudad de francófona donde para mí donde
aquí la lengua dominante es la lengua
francesa es que tarde algún costado que
a ustedes les agrade de eso y de toda la
historia se ve reflejado eso sólo
algunos de los cuentos absolutamente yo
creo que eso se refleja en muchísimos de
los cuentos hay detalles hay
características muy interesantes que
ojalá que que puedan descubrirlas
ustedes los lectores lo que nos están
viendo yo creo que se inscribe muy bien
se pinta muy bien en la ciudad de
distintos ángulos y hay detalles que tal
vez no conocíamos y que también van a
descubrir
cuando tienen tres son 25 cuento son 25
autores distintos de dónde son los
sensores yo sé que están dos que
trabajan que trabajan uno que trabaja
todavía acá es bufo valència y otro que
es diego kreimer que trabajo acá ambos
tienen publican ahí sus historias de
dónde son los otros los hemos tratado
para no olvidarme porque tenemos de
origen mexicano colombiano peruano
venezolano salvadoreño cubano boliviano
brasileño y español y los lugares de
residencia de todos esos escritores en
su mayoría bueno sabemos que hay
montreal toronto calgary es que hay
otros lugares y vancouver en vancouver
montreal por supuesto material es el
centro en el centro de toronto y lo
bueno de todas partes
[Música]
bueno yo creo que voy a leer la pregunta
de el concurso así de que pilas todos
dijiste que pagan un libro de regalo no
este entonces este libro va para el
ganador y el ganador o la ganadora es la
primera persona que responda a la
pregunta es porque en realidad no es la
cuestión tiene que ver con el
mentalmente y con faye 6 hay mensajes
que yo sí veo y mensajes que se ven
desde otro lado dejen mensajes que
tengan primero o no dependiendo de
factores voy a hacer
escribir los nombres de los
participantes y vamos a hacer sorteos
entonces la pregunta ojo y una serie de
televisión basada en una famosa novela
escrita por una canadiense inicia su
tercera temporada el 5 de junio
es una novela distópica que imagina un
mundo donde las mujeres han perdido
todos sus sistemas
es un sorteo de la pregunta cuál es el
nombre de la serie y el nombre de la
escritora en torno a nadien sé que está
presentando una tercera temporada el 5
de junio
famosa es muy fácil es fácil fotos
saludos
chavarría ramírez es bonito programa los
saludos de costa rica costarricense
rodríguez charlize de montreal el don de
seducción incluso se percibe la
distancia
me encantaría conocer montreal y una de
las maneras
jose es a través del concurso y venir a
buscar el libro
[Risas]
[Música]
me había olvidado de decirles que el
ganador del concurso no tiene que
preocuparse no tiene que venir a buscar
la carne
cuando lo que no nos dijeron ustedes
cuatro mientras que ahora mañana donde
la presentación oficial del libro están
todos invitados es el día de mañana 19
horas y media 30 en la en el marco del
festival blue metrópoli por supuesto en
la librería las américas van a estar
presentes los 25 escritores no sé no va
a ser muy difícil por distintas
distintas razones pero se van a vivir
tal vez tal vez entre la presentación en
montreal y la presentación en toronto
los 'santos' el toronto es el día martes
7 de mayo a las 6 de la tarde en la
librería damon natalie que es una de las
librerías más hermosas que tiene canadá
el libro historia de toronto tuvo
muchísimo éxito en canadá esperamos
entonces seguramente la historia de
montreal va a continuar por el mismo
camino hay una primera edición así que
aprovechen porque la portada es preciosa
y es hermoso es preciosa muy bien y de
además eso y montreal mítico y un
montreal modelo
el tiempo pasa como agua entre los dedos
lunar luego virtud tenías si lo que yo
quería decir es que la manera de
responder es sobre los comentarios así
como están mandando saludos son buenos
en este caso hay que mandar el
comentario ya hay alguien que puso el
nombre de acertó listas y la de todos la
escritora
falta el nombre de la serie
los pongo ya directamente el nombre en
el de papel y en el papelito y hacemos y
empezamos para hacer el sorteo es
fantástico entonces como el tiempo pasa
tan rápido vamos a pasar a los temas no
sé si tenemos tiempo leonardo para la
aplicación o no
pasamos la aplicación no hay aplicación
entonces vamos a los temas que
trabajamos esta semana y que no les
recordamos la pregunta una vez más antes
de pasar los temas si bueno el nombre de
la escritora que escribió esta serie de
la cual
es el nombre de la escritora que
escribió un libro en el cual se inspiró
una serie que ya entra en su tercera
temporada tiene tanto éxito que empieza
el 5 de junio la tercera temporada y es
una historia de una de las mujeres y
etcétera etcétera entonces queremos
saber el nombre de la escritora y el
nombre de la serie no hay forma de
confundir y siguió tratando de esconder
bueno leonora tú nos hablan de una
investigación que explica por qué hay
inmigrantes que se integran muy bien así
me interesó muchísimo esta historia en
realidad es una presentación que hizo
una investigadora de la universidad york
que se llama helen así que es una
investigadora psicóloga que si viene
interesando desde hace muchísimo tiempo
en el tema de los de la inmigración a
canadá pero sobre todo de las barreras
que enfrentan los inmigrantes para poder
insertarse
tener éxito laboral entonces lo que ella
dice es que ya hablamos bastante sobre
esos temas sobre cuáles son los
obstáculos que enfrentan los inmigrantes
mucho menos se habló qué es lo que hace
que haya inmigrantes que se integran de
una manera muy exitosa aquí en canadá
decidió investigar a partir de estos
premios que otorga el que creo que es el
banco de canadá -que donde elige a 25
canal anualmente 25 canadienses de
origen inmigrante que se destacan en
canadá y que de alguna manera
contribuyen también en esta sociedad a
partir de 30 de esas personas ella
escuchó las entrevistas analizó se
encontró con ellos encontró que la razón
que explica en gran parte el hecho de
que hayan tenido tanto éxito para
integrarse es que son extremadamente
gentes abiertas a la experiencia
migratoria en la sociedad de acogida
tienen una curiosidad por conocer todo
sobre el nuevo lugar también le tienen
dice ella una motivación fundamental que
es la de
relaciones con la gente local entonces
esa apertura esa curiosidad esas ganas
de integrarse a la sociedad juega un
papel preponderante en el éxito de estas
personas para más detalles
rcn punto o sea ahí van a encontrar la
entrevista de leonora y bueno yo
recuerdo nuevamente por si acaso la
pregunta es una serie de televisión
basada en una famosa novela escrita por
una canadiense inicia su tercera
temporada en el 5 de junio y queremos
saber el nombre de la escritora y el
nombre de la serie entonces continuamos
en por acá paloma si tú nos hablas de
carne pero no carmen la vecina la carmen
de bizet carmen de georges bizet la
ópera de montalt está presentando
después de 15 años de no presentar
ninguna versión de carmen está
presentando la la carmen de georges
bizet pero es una carmen nueva renovada
diría yo y rescatar
[Risas]
pero bueno es una puesta en escena de un
gran cineasta canadiense que por primera
vez hace la puesta en escena de una
ópera de sabina no internamente ha hecho
un montón de películas muy conocidas
aquí en canadá y presenta entonces está
está puesta en escena que hizo que
preparó durante por lo menos un año
entero lo que es raro para un nuevo una
ópera de este tipo por generalmente se
ven tres semanas y ya la presentan el
durante un año estuvo en colaboración
con los con los con los actores con los
cantantes con los cantantes y con los
escenógrafos y todo entonces está
presentando una una carmen muy moderna
374 personas participan cada noche en el
escenario comienza mañana de hecho hay
bases pero hay los solistas los
cantantes los músicos los bailarines los
extras los artesanos los que hicieron la
escenografía y el vestuario
entonces yo entrevisté
a michel ballack que es el director
artístico de la ópera de monte lee que
habla un perfecto español
entonces me encantó conversar con él y
me explicó la historia de carmen y me
dijo que carmen esta y cualquier carne
porque la carmen de georges bizet dice
es una carmen muy moderna porque es una
mujer fuerte valiente libre entonces por
eso vale la pena seguir la viendo en
pues carmen denise y escuchen esta
entrevista en el sainete o sea con el
director artístico de la ópera de
montreal
leonardo jiménez tú no hablas de blog
de los blogs
joel lo vi sufrir en la semana tan
fácilmente
así que te voy a dejar te voy a dejar
expresar peligro igual no no lo igual
les cuento que es una tecnología nueva
con la que se está digamos
afianzando ciertos procesos que se
hacían antes de otra manera y se supone
que es mucho más seguro
lo interesante de esta noticia es que la
primera vez que se hace con traspasos de
dinero entre dos bancos centrales uno el
banco de canadá y otro el banco de
singapur
van a venir los hackers bueno es que es
mucho más seguro por el tipo de
estructura que tiene es la cadena de
liga y la seguridad tiene que ver con
uno de los bloques de la cadena sino
justamente la cadena es uno atrás del
otro y para romper uno de que romper
todo si es bastante difícil bueno les
cuento más o menos de qué se trata y
suscribiendo algunas publicaciones para
aprender de qué se trata
media noche en este caso se extiende a
dos bancos centrales que intercambian
divisas por primera vez muy bien y él
público en general que es como
bitcoin bitcoin funciona con block
change la misma tecnología pero esta
tecnología se está usando para un montón
de cosas para contratos para hacer la
liquidación de sueldos para enviar
dinero para un montón un montón de cosas
cuestiones de salud ahora se está
empezando a usar en todas esas cosas y
particularmente lo interesante de esto
es que se hacía localmente ahora los
bancos empezaron a hacer este tipo de
de intercambio monetario a distancia
gracias a esta tecnología fantástico hay
algún mensaje más el embargo cuatro
personas que han contestado el paso con
con con la participación eso ahí están
todos les repetimos nuevamente la
pregunta es una hay una serie de
televisión basada en una famosa novela
escrita por una canadiense que inicia su
tercera temporada el 5 de junio y hay
que decir que son mujeres que han
perdido sus derechos y donde las
aquellas que son fértiles se ven
obligadas a tener hijos para los hombres
poderosos y para sus esposas que son
infértiles
para participar en este curso viene el
nombre de la artista de la escritora
pero no el del libro de la serie así que
solamente la marca todavía directamente
no está nuevo bromwich sí sí es ese en
el nuevo sí que es cierto así que por
ahora estamos ahí yo tengo
el nombre escrito falta el apellido
cuando ponga el resto de la refuerza
bueno
yo por mi parte les voy a hablar de una
entrevista que hice con david aarón test
que es el director del coro femenino
armonía de méxico
[Música]
entonces este es un coro femenino y
estuvimos se lleva a cabo en la ciudad
de ottawa en este momento en la ciudad
de latino pero también hay conciertos en
ottawa de este encuentro a una voz que
es organizado por la unam
canadá en gatineau y
s
los conciertos este la particularidad de
este coro armonía es que es un coro
femenino y conversando con él y hablando
acá también entre colegas durante la
semana nos preguntábamos si sí que lo
más difícil que es dirigir un coro
femenino tiene otros desafíos distintos
a los de dirigir un coro mixto o un coro
masculino y bueno y si se necesita un
repertorio y él nos decía que
efectivamente los repertorios tienen que
ser escogidos y nos hablaba de vivaldi
entre otras cosas y de schubert que han
escrito música para especificar
específicamente para coro femeninos se
supone en el caso de vivaldi se dice que
acá son al barítono si no hay bajos
bueno pero deben haber mujeres que
tenemos es graves
en contra de sólo cuatro las voces
femeninas también yo he cantado un coro
que hacía
obras solamente para mujeres son
extraordinarias he visto unos rusos que
cambian en unas iglesias perdidas que no
es bueno
yo los invito a escuchar a escuchar la
entrevista con david aarón test en
nuestro sitio internet
seguimos aprovechó ya que estamos para
agradecer a nuestros técnicos hoy y se
trata de ese logro encontrar toda una
formación en el papelito
bueno ya lo conocemos si ya voy a comer
los links
para eso
charla actual charlatán
[Risas]
[Música]
ahora si nos ponemos ahora dentro le
pongo acá
muy bien
[Risas]
esta idea de sortear un libro fue de
nuestro amigo de colombia que había
dicho en este momento si fue a raíz de
la entrevista que hicimos entonces el
libro le atrajo muchísimo dijo porque
nos sortean uno para nosotros es
excelente la idea
para acá
si ser insular
y el príncipe eduardo
se tiene que enviar la dirección para el
premio
[Música]
vamos un segundo por favor van a dejar
otro libro podríamos parar
un minuto
[Risas]
nuevamente el tiempo pasa como agua
entre los dedos eso fue todo el tiempo
del que dispone
los otros para que sepan que nos quedan
45 luis balderas
y participar
y el último que había participado es
nelson contra rincón
gracias por haber participado les
recordamos que la versión audio de este
problema este problema de este programa
la pueden escuchar en rcn puntos ya este
viernes el sábado y el domingo 5 de mayo
saludos a todos muchas gracias a ustedes
allá del otro lado del micro muy bien
chau adiós tenemos extraerlo
[Música]